depuis qu'il a été abandonné dans les
écoles publiques le port de l'uniforme
fait régulièrement débat je suis contre
la blouse je trouve que le blues détruit
toute personnalité si les enfants sont
généralement libres de s'habiller comme
ils le souhaitent le maire de Marignane
près de Marseille aimerait bien voir
dans ses établissements scolaires le
retour de ces fameuses uniformes je
trouve qu'il était essentiel pour
l'égalité des enfants vestimentaires de
passer par par l'uniforme dans un être
envoyé au ministre de l'Éducation le
Maire propose aussi de sensibiliser les
enfants à leur identité française en
chantant la Marseillaise tous les lundis
devant le drapeau tricolore une demande
qui a fait réagir les parents d'élèves
je pense que 80% des enfants ne
connaissent pas la Marseillaise
malheureusement alors un maire veut
imposer l'uniforme et la Marseillaise à
l'école est une bonne idée
alors est-ce une bonne idée voilà oui
oui oui oui oui oui c'est une très bonne
idée parce qu'on sait qu'à l'école il y
a beaucoup de moquerie beaucoup de
discriminations souvent en raison des
différences et des origines sociales du
milieu social et un des premiers signes
extérieurs de richesse ou de pauvreté ce
sont les vêtements
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi moi j'ai changé d'avis là-dessus il
y a quelques années aujourd'hui ce n'est
plus possible pour deux raisons d'abord
l'uniforme je vous rappelle à l'image de
ce qu'on voit derrière Cyril c'est le
sexisme vous allez mettre les petites
filles en jupe les garçons en pantalon
le Président
c'est le grand retour du sexisme ce
n'est pas possible et deuxièmement
aujourd'hui pour les enfants quel qu'il
soit s'habiller c'est un geste fort
c'est à travers les habits qu'on
s'exprime qu'on gagne de la liberté etc
remettre un uniforme c'est du passé
c'est très très vieux et des
réactionnaires blues on te parle par
exemple comme on vit comme il faut en
Angleterre ils ont le petit pantalon
avec le sweat qui est sympa et les
filles et les filles bah les filles
elles se mettent en jeu ou les pantalons
elles ont le droit et talons aussi
il y a pas de souci moi je trouve que
c'est très bien justement pour donner
cette idée de cohésion de vivre ensemble
et que tous les gamins soient ensemble
et soit fier d'être dans la même école
et avec l'école d'à côté etc l'école
c'est pas l'armée
surtout on ira
tout seul
veulent s'habiller en jean basket avec
un petit pull qui sent la Marseillaise
moi je l'ai chanté à l'armée à Marseille
moi je suis avec je crois avec Benjamin
on doit aller les deux salles avoir fait
l'armée je l'ai chanté moi c'est bien de
chanter la Marseillaise mais pourquoi
elle a chanté le lundi matin à l'école
il y en a ils ont peut-être pas envie de
chanter la Marseillaise les paroles
elles sont peut-être une fois on s'en
foutent en fait mais justement
je préférerais qu'on donne d'autres
moyens à l'école pour qu'on mette des
instits des vrais incites pas des mecs
mais non parce que on met pas les moyens
sur les sur l'école on met pas les vrais
moyens et là vous voulez mettre des
uniformes mettez des vrais moyens pour
l'école aider les enseignants à chaque
fois tu sais l'enseignement tes enfants
ça a pas de prix faut arrêter avec les
phrases comme ça ça coûte moins cher tu
sais ce qu'il faut en ce moment il
recrute des profs qui ont tiré à la
tombola au bout de deux mois ils leur
ont demandé 6 fois 6 36 c'est bon vous
pouvez profiter c'est ça qui se passe
dans nos écoles c'est ça qui se passe
dans nos écoles c'est pas uniforme la
Marseillaise donner des moyens à l'école
c'est ça qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que les gens ne sont plus
fiers de la France ils ne sont plus
fiers d'être en France et d'être
français donc si à partir de tout petit
à partir de l'école on leur apprend les
maths le français et être fier de son
pays à être respectueux aussi de
l'environnement enfin tout ça c'est des
choses qui savent on dit que les enfants
j'ai décidé tout petit tu apprends un
enfant à être fier d'être français et à
vouloir le meilleur pour son pays et ben
en grandissant ce sera un adulte
responsable et respectueux c'est pas
l'école de le faire c'est aux parents de
reprendre l'éducation c'est aux parents
de reprendre
pour apprendre l'école est pas là pour
éduquer éduquer vos enfants quand ils
arrivent avec des valeurs vous vous
confondez l'école vous croyez qu'on
jette l'enfant à l'école et il va
prendre
soin de à nager apprenez à mon enfant à
dire bonjour
c'est pas vrai le choix ils ont plus
droit de faire plein de trucs c'est pas
vrai mélange vous mélangez tout le temps
de l'école je vais le mettre à l'école
ils ont tout lui apprendre à l'école ils
vont lui apprendre à dire bonjour à
nager
c'est à toi d'apprendre à ton gosse à
nager c'est un problème parmi tant
d'autres bah oui si tu as pas le temps
d'aller à prendre ton gosse à nager fais
pas
avec son petit
bikini là problème
non mais je te trouve d'une démagogie
absolument en fait c'est bon c'est parce
qu'on est en tellement paire de repères
perd d'autorité perte de tout que oui on
va faire jouer aujourd'hui à l'école
quelque chose qu'on ne peut plus faire
c'est l'école qui doit faire l'autorité
mais en fait d'autorité est-ce que c'est
l'école selon toi qui doit faire
l'autorité pour qu'on respecte pas les
profs bah parce que c'est mal éduqué au
départ c'est aux parents d'éduquer pour
respecter prof c'est pas parce que tu
vas leur mettre un survêtement noir de
la même couleur qui vont chanter la
Marseillaise alors ça va changer de
choses l'uniforme c'est très bien parce
que justement c'est anticonsommation
anticonsumérisme anticapitalisme et ça
permet à tout le monde je pense ça
serait pas mal uniforme
tous les jours non c'est que lundi
ce serait tout le temps et c'est très
bien c'est moins discriminant et il faut
savoir qu'en France République et au
dessus de tout et l'uniforme permet les
uniformes les milliers millions
d'uniformes il en faut pas qu'un non
pas encore
différents
vous vous êtes dans la France des années
70 des années 50 et vous êtes les
premiers à acheter des Air Max à 150 qui
a fait ça merci vous voulez faire des
trucs zarmacs c'est bien mais vous êtes
les premiers
informatiques tu trouves ça normal que
les enfants aujourd'hui en France dans
les écoles ne connaissent pas la
Marseillaise ne connaît pas l'histoire
donc c'est pas j'ai pas dit que c'était
normal
moi j'aurais bien voulu la faire ils
n'ont pas voulu
ils ont du pif
ils sont forts Daniel non mais
excuse-moi tu parles de l'école dans les
années 60-70 dans ces années là quand un
prof arrivé tous les états
et on chantait mon chapeau frelons
et ça veut dire mettons-nous joyeusement
au travail relish and the on adorait ça
chanter ça c'est une France
c'était les spectateurs
[Applaudissements]